we were meeting up at the Embassy to
collect our visas and this [ __ ]
that story I couldn't [ __ ] believe oh
my god that was like one of the worst
days like you can't write that [ __ ] was
horrible all because you didn't have a
[ __ ] backpack I I carried my passport
in my jeans pocket which I'm hearing
people have like oh my god I'm like
cringing hearing that I'm like okay I
have traveled like all over the world
just having my my passport I'm up okay I
have lost it before and you guys know I
have I lost it in America as well I
found it though luckily but anyways so I
was going to the train station to pick
up you know go to the Train go to London
and as my train arrived I'm like I
always tap my pockets right to make it I
was there I've tapped my pockets it's
not in yeah Anna I'm like bark and
what's running through my head is like
all of this like months of work I feel
bad for the company they paid for
lawyers like all these people who have
like banked on me coming and I've put so
much work into this myself and other
people in us yeah I also have a mental
break dad don't think I've ever like had
that much of a like quick mental
breakdown in my life and it was like
gradually getting worse and like the
hour I couldn't find it
yeah I scoured this train station a tiny
train station in Wales it's called like
flemeth's you can look it up ah it's
literally just like a platform
there's nowhere this should've gone
where I couldn't have found it right
could not find it
checked my car quickly drove home to
find it didn't find it came back to
check again couldn't find it go into the
police station literally everything I
could not find you I've no idea where
what happened I have no idea I have my
passport and then eventually it was
getting like 3:00 4:00 p.m. and I was
like okay I'm gonna just call up the
British government and tell them hey can
you count to my passport I want to apply
for another one and that whole thing was
an ordeal and then my main concern was
like all right well I lost my passport
do I have to restart the whole visa
process again yeah luckily the embassy
were like no as long as you have like
the certificate which I didn't lose
great I could redo it sorry [ __ ]
look I had to scramble to get a new
passport and that was the whole thing
and I got one within like five days
luckily and luckily it all went well
like it was just so stressful on top of
like already this stress there
I was already at my limit with stress
that whole period because this whole
thing yeah
and that was just like the full light I
don't know breakdown that was horrible
and I think I like joked about it on
Twitter but like I was like not okay
that's dead and the worst part is right
is when you [ __ ] up this badly you can
accept that you [ __ ] up but it's it's
messaging your friends being like hey
I'm not gonna be in London and I unless
you're like oh why what's something like
I lost my passport
I remember reading my text cuz I was
waiting for you outside the embassy when
when when you're like I get a message
from Connor being like I'm gonna be a
bit like 30 minutes late I'll get a
coffee and III see the event unfold as
he's just texting me so he goes yeah I
can't find my passport I'm just gonna go
look for it quickly and then it just
hits you like just breaking down every
message you and it just ends we're yeah
I don't know I don't think I can go and
I'm still annoyed to the stickers I've
got around this is a very small town
where I lost it I went around like every
shop in that area I said literally
everyone in that area hey if you find
this passport can you call me right away
because if not I'm gonna just cancel it
today I still never heard anything yeah
I like I was crazy and I dunno how I
lost it